a new effort aims to help bridge the
black home
ownership gap in southern nevada the
coalition to make homes possible hopes
to get
25 000 families to achieve home
ownership over the next 10 years by
offering help
in down payment assistance financial
coaching credit repair among others
the las vegas mayor carolyn goodman was
among several to make the announcement
outside of city hall
this morning including raiders football
player nelson aguilar who expressed
support to help close the home ownership
gap
right here in southern nevada that the
problem is just
the lack of information you know people
are hesitant they might have enough you
know
find they might have enough financial
stability but not have enough education
and understanding
that they can follow through with you
know putting down the down payments
in southern nevada only 35 percent of
black families are homeowners according
to homey
a tech based real estate company who
announced the creation of the coalition
their next step is to host a workshop on
february 27th
the guidance is free visit 8newsnow.com
for the details